[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal préparé par la
rédaction voici les titres en images de
ce 15 décembre 2016
une nouvelle plateforme de financement
participatif lancé à saint quentin en
yvelines et sky invest doit permettre
aux entrepreneurs de booster le
développement de leurs activités
la signature attrapé hier d'un accord
qui devrait permettre de sortir enfin du
tunnel l'enfouissement d'une partie de
la nationale 10 qui traverse la commune
pourrait être terminée en 2021 et puis
cette dernière réunion des élus de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines hier soir et des tensions qui
perdurent entre majorité et opposition
résultat le vote des compétences n'est
toujours pas possible
un an après l'arrivée de cinq nouvelles
communes
le crowdfunding ou financement
participatif dispositif qui permet de
faire appel à un grand nombre de
personnes afin de financer un projet via
internet principalement c'est un
dispositif qui se développe depuis à ces
dernières années dorénavant saint
quentin en yvelines a sa propre
plateforme de crowdfunding pour aider
les entreprises du territoire son nom
sky invest le lancement officiel a eu
lieu hier les explications avec
haussmann vendeurs des lancements de sky
invest mercredi 14 décembre la
plateforme de financement participatif a
pour but d'aider les entreprises à se
développer plus rapidement pour mettre
en place cette plateforme
l'agglomération a collaboré avec
casquette ou une veste une société de
financement
je crois que le financement est le
maître mot de l'entreprise et que sky
veste qui se marie avec coeur ce que
tout une veste c'est à une belle
perspective pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui que
chacun sait qu'il ya de grands besoins
l'investissement le sens de l'entreprise
sont des choses qui se se développe de
plus en plus et parallèlement il ya
beaucoup d'épargnants dans notre pays et
cette épargne vous pourrez l'utiliser
pour contribuer au développement d'une
entreprise grâce à la plateforme sky
invest et le choix des entreprises sera
rigoureux le dossier sera présenté à
comité d'audit
on fera ce qu'on appelle des diots
diligence dans le jargon c'est à dire
qu'on va regarder si ce qui est expliqué
vraies perspectives sont réalistes
non non il faudra quand même
sérieusement présenter patte blanche
avant de pouvoir être financés
contrairement à d'autres site de
financement participatif tels que kiss
kiss bang bang
le sky invest n'a vocation qu'à financer
les entreprises
c'est un projet qui va bientôt fêter ses
20 ans le dossier de l'enfouissement
d'une partie de la nationale 10 attrapés
cela semble devenir une réalité
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des acteurs du
dossier est à régions et départements
agglomérations et villes ont signé hier
un accord de financement les travaux
pourraient débuter dès 2018 précision
avec nicolas quere lovitz et anne-laure
l'anguille ces images vont elles bientôt
appartenir au passé avec 80 mille
véhicules qui l'empruntent tous les
jours la nationale 10 est un enjeux
structurants depuis une vingtaine
d'années pour la ville de trappes ce
mercredi 14 décembre les collectivités
ont enfin signé le protocole d'accord
pour l'enfouissement partiel de lax sur
près de 800 mètres
un projet de 95 millions d'euros dont 28
à la charge de la région ile de france
cette saignée urbaine au milieu de
trappes les trappistes de la méritais
pas j'ai toujours pensé qu'il fallait
réparer cette cicatrice qu'il fallait
futur et ce territoire et permettre à la
ville de trappes de redevenir
ville j'allais dire où il fait bon vivre
et où les deux morceaux de la ville sont
recoller les travaux de l'enfouissement
partiel de la nationale 10 devrait
débuter en 2018 la couverture de l'axé
la modification de deux carrefours
permettront de redessiner en profondeur
la commune
on alla de l'espace pour faire du pour
faire du paysage pour faire des choses
qu'ils soient de vrais en entrée de
ville est donc d'accord on rentre dans
trappe on rentre dans une ville qui a eu
qu à une allure qui a un paysage que
c'est à mes yeux très important si le
calendrier des travaux est tenue à
l'aménagement total de la nationale 10
sera bouclée en 2021 soit 23 ans après
les premières études consacrées aux
projets et s'étire également qu'un
nouveau pas vient d'être franchi dans le
projet de construction d'un nouveau
commissariat elle encourt la présidente
de la région ile de france valérie
pécresse a profité du déplacement à
trappes pour visiter les locaux de
l'actuel commissariat d'elancourt est
pour évaluer les conditions de travail
des agents une visite qui intervenait
donc en en un monde de la signature de
cette convention ou à la région s'engage
à rénover plusieurs commissariats en ile
de france à hauteur de 30 % le projet
d'elancourt lui a été lancée il ya une
dizaine d'années l'investissement
nécessaire pourrait se porter jusqu'à 20
millions d'euros rien n'est encore fait
l'état doit d'abord réalisé une étude
pour déterminer les besoins les élus
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et singulière bourges il faut
que ce souhaité que je les vois leurs
projets
nouveau commissariat d'agde
les rations qui commence à avoir une
petite expérience
exister des différents commissariats de
france je peux dire qu'effectivement sur
deux
d'elancourt mérite
au minimum une innovation dans le reste
de l'actualité hier soir se tenait le
dernier conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines dernier conseil
communautaire pour l'année 2016 et
l'ordre du jour étaient plutôt chargée
pour les 75 élu avec 60 points à l'ordre
du jour bonsoir nicollin bonsoir 58
précisément wilfried pour un conseil
communautaire qui aura duré à 4h30 en
tout et comme d'habitude certains points
ont fait débat entre majorité de droite
et opposition de gauche un point
notamment celui concernant la définition
de l'intérêt communautaire c'est un acte
fondateur pour l'agglomération élargi à
12 villes cet intérêt communautaire vous
le voyez à l'écran permet de définir ce
qui sera ou non de la compétence de
l'agglomération en matière par exemple
de développement économique
d'aménagement urbain ou encore de voirie
la majorité a proposé de copier l'ancien
modèle qui prévalait à 7 et de l'élargir
aux cinq nouvelles villes de faire en
sorte un copier coller mais en plus
grand problème ce point n'a pas requis
les deux tiers des voix est nécessaire
pour entrer en vigueur
alors pourquoi ces élus principalement
de gauche ont décidé de ne pas accepter
cette proposition
eh bien ils réclament plus de temps
selon toutes leurs interrogations n'ont
pas été levées et ils s'inquiètent de la
mainmise de l'agglomération sur certains
sujets écoutez à ce propos bertrand ou
lyon le maire socialiste de magny les
hameaux
il faut qu'on continue discute et qu'on
rapproche les choses maintenant voilà il
a été choisi de faire un vote tout à
l'heure j'ai proposé au président de
reporter la délibération tout simplement
c'est pas un aveu d'échec de reporter
une délibération c'est justement de
sortir par le haut et puis de pouvoir
derrière continuez finalisé on peut très
bien se laisser encore deux trois mois
et pour espérer trouver un accord entre
les élus la séance a même été suspendus
plus d'un quart d'heure mais rien à
faire à les voix nécessaires n'ont pas
été trouvés le président de
l'agglomération michel laugier regrette
d'ailleurs le retard pris surtout pour
les cinq nouvelles villes et on les
écoute ça fait déjà un an qu'on
travaille je veux dire et si on se met
ça ne se met pas d'accord maintenant
comment voulez vous qu'on se donne
encore plus de temps alors c'est quoi la
la fin c'est quoi ces corps ne votent
pas et si on ne vote pas tous les
intérêts seront communautaires
il n'y aura plus rien pour les villes
et comme vient de le dire michel logis à
l'instant les élus de l'agglomération
ont encore un an pour trouver un accord
sinon c'est le maximum de compétences
qu'autorise la loi qui sera alors
d'ordre communautaire et ça personne ne
semble le vouloir
les élus vont donc devoir se mettre
rapidement d'accord dès le mois de
janvier ça risque d'être en plus agitée
avec les échéances électorales d'autres
points ont-ils fait aussi débat lors de
cette séance hier soir alors rien de
cette importance ma noter quand même que
les élus ont voté en faveur de
l'extension du périmètre de gestion du
syndicat qui s'occupe de l'eau potable
sur une grande partie du territoire
le but in fine et c'est d'arriver à un
seul syndicat qui gère l'eau potable
pour toutes les villes enfin les élus
rossi pris acte du rapport d'activités
2015 de vélo police le gestionnaire du
vélodrome nationale un rapport
d'activité qui révèlent un déficit
supérieur à 800 milles euros l'an passé
aussi il faudra de trouver des solutions
d'urgence pour ce vélodrome merci
nicolas on quitte l'agglomération de 50
ans ni lui ni nous ne partons pas très
loin nous partons pour une commune
voisine c'est celle de saint cyr l'école
bernard de bain le maire vient d'y
inaugurer un nouveau multi accueil les
farfadets un nouveau pas donc dans
l'accueil de ces enfants mais aussi dans
le cadre du projet de la commune elle
l'écologie la crèche est en effet 100%
écolo toiture végétale panneaux solaires
isolation laine de bois avec ce nouveau
multi accueil la ville a souhaité mettre
en avant le bien être et l'écologie pour
les enfants le toit végétalisé les
panneaux solaires la structure bois pour
la construction et pour l'isolation
ainsi que tout l'équipement auguste ce
soit les lampes led
ça fait partie aussi
2 non seulement de l'allemande mais
surtout c'est aussi une économie pour la
ville en frais de fonctionnement
construit en lieu et place de l'ancien
square du 19 mars le bâtiment de 670
mètres carrés pourra accueillir 35
enfants de 0 à 3 ans entre 8 heures et
18 heures si le regroupement d'un
multi-accueil de 15 bears de 15 places
et un autre
et une structure qui s'appelait
initialement une halte garderie de la
place donc ces deux structures ont
fusionné avec les équipes pour ouvrir un
nouveau multi accueil d'une capacité de
35 places avec les cinq équipes de
chaque côté existantes dont ce qui fait
une équipe au total une étude
pluridisciplinaire de dix agents avec ce
multi-accueil la ville atteint
aujourd'hui une capacité d'accueil de
300 enfants sécurité à présent la police
nationale de versailles a organisé ce
jeudi 15 décembre une réunion sur la
sensibilisation sur le vol par ruse
l'objectif c'est de conseiller les
personnes les plus touchées par ce
phénomène pour éviter cette situation
nicolas d'andré utilisé une fausse
qualité pour entrer chez vous et dérober
vos biens c'est le délit de vol par ruse
commis par certains délinquants
une conférence organisée ce jeudi 15
décembre par la police nationale de
versailles visait à se prévenir de ces
situations
c'est un phénomène assez compliqué assez
difficile à interrompre parce que il ne
se produit pas sur la voie publique se
produit si ce produit au domicile des
victimes
donc les patrouilles qui sont dans les
rues ils sont assez massive
la carte de police elle est très
identifiable c'est une petite carte de
crédit alors qu'on sait que parfois les
voyous utilisent des cartes qui ne
ressemble à kim ambassades et grande
carte blanche utilisation de l'antre
bailleur composer le 17 en cas de doute
ce sont des réflexes à adopter chaque
année près de 15 vols par ruse sont
répertoriés à versailles les voyous
agissant général entre 11h et 14h chez
les personnes les plus vulnérables les
personnes âgées
on est curieux de connaître qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour être ne pas être
concernés dans les arnaques
on vient
pour avoir d'autres d'autres
renseignements d'autres notre
d'indication sur toutes les façons dont
on peut être trop grande et quand on est
âgé et handicapé d'éviter certains
pièges il y en a que je connais mais
avec je connais pas donc comment repérer
les arnaques
le centre communal d'action sociale de
versailles libre des plateaux repas chez
les 172 personnes vulnérables recensé un
moyen pour la commune de lutter contre
le risque de vol par ruse
à travers ce contact les services de la
ville sont informés l'éventuel risque
pour les personnes âgées de contact
anormaux et peuvent prévenir les
services de police avec lesquels il ya
une coordination constante l'article 311
tiré 4 du code pénal sanctionne de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende ce type de délit c'est la fin de
ce journal demain vous avez rendez vous
avec nikola kirillovitch pour le 7-8
l'hebdo l'essentiel de la semaine
commentait vous en avez l'habitude par
nos invités vous pouvez revoir tous nos
programmes sur notre site internet grâce
au replay et puis est bien trop ce
bientôt ce sera aussi possible sur votre
tablette et sur vos mobiles grâce à la
nouvelle application qui sera
prochainement disponible sur amazon
google play et l'apple store très bonne
soirée le journal revient lundi
[Musique]